this is a bitcoin mine hidden deep in
the mountains of sichuan in china
[Music]
and its rival is on the other side of
the planet at a former factory that used
to make denim for levi's
you see the transformers lined up on the
outside we have a lot of megawatts
these two miners make money by providing
the massive computing power that's
required to process and record a high
volume of cryptocurrency transactions
business was soaring as bitcoin hit new
highs in early 2021.
it's hard to sleep you go to bed at
night you wake up you're looking holy
crap it's still up
last year china controlled 70 percent of
the global processing power that runs
the bitcoin network
and that means the majority of the
cryptocurrency's global transactions
are routed through these computers in
china and recorded by miners here
so a group of us miners is raising
hundreds of millions of dollars to win a
larger share of bitcoin's processing
power when
capitalism in the states decides it
wants to get into a market and get into
an industry
it moves heavy capital there they say
their work is also meant to protect
bitcoin
industry insiders say the chinese
government has already cracked down on
some crypto entrepreneurs
and could potentially disrupt global
trading by asking miners in china to
block certain users from making
transactions
it's better for cryptocurrency to be
spread around the globe so that bitcoin
cannot be manipulated by any single
government
i think there will be competition it's
more and more human resources
technology resources are putting into
this particular new segment
the battle over bitcoin mining will
decide who controls the infrastructure
that powers the cryptocurrency
started mining during the previous
bitcoin rally in 2017
and this is one of the sites he works
with that has mined about 8 000 bitcoins
over the past three years
generating about 28 million dollars in
revenue over that time period
miners need cheap electricity which is
abundant in some parts of china
thanks to dams and coal power plants
that were built by the state in the past
decade
that electricity then powers fast
machines that are necessary to solve
mathematical problems in order to
eventually mint new coins
china is home to the vast majority of
mining equipment production
and so miners like lou always have
speedy access to the best technology
like this cooling system
but the industry in china lives with
uncertainty
lou asks to keep the location of the
site a secret because he says he's not
sure if the government will crack down
one day
while mining itself isn't illegal
virtual currency trading and crypto
exchanges are banned in china
because they're seen as risky to the
country's financial system
in the past few months bitcoin industry
insiders have said that beijing accused
some chinese miners of money laundering
and froze their credit cards
making it difficult for miners to pay
operating costs
the chinese government did not respond
to a request for comment
so to help miners develop their business
despite the risks
lou offers loans so miners don't need to
go through chinese banks
his company bobble finance lends
cryptocurrencies to about 300 miners
including the owners of this site so
that they can purchase more
equipment at a lower cost and then
maintaining the machine itself
including repairs and chinese miners are
now facing growing competition from
overseas
in the united states we have massive
infrastructure power infrastructure and
building infrastructure that's already
been built out
and we can convert facilities into large
data mining facilities
russell kan is an american miner who
scouts the u.s for abandoned factories
and converts them into mining facilities
his goal
raised cash to develop industrial scale
mining in the u.s
where until a few years ago most miners
ran small diy
operations this is my housing for my
computers so that
the heat is vented outside
so core scientific has built a team with
former executives from microsoft and
myspace
and put together an ambitious business
plan
we have ernst young audited financials
we have a strong balance sheet
we check a lot of boxes for
institutional investors that a chinese
minor does not check
the strategy worked in the past two
years the company has raised 95 million
dollars
and secured a 20 million dollar loan to
install mining rigs and facilities
including a former denim factory in
north carolina
and a former carpet factory in georgia
core scientific power infrastructure can
handle the latest mining equipment which
kan says
usually consumes approximately 100
megawatt hours of electricity to mine
one bitcoin
that's the same amount of electricity
used to watch television continuously
for about 98 years
and tunnels that were once used to cool
the factory are now being used to keep
chips from overheating
we've got the ability to process 200
000 gallons of chilled water through
these pipes to keep the temperature in
the building down
kan hopes all this will help him offset
a long-running technological
disadvantage
he was usually about four months behind
his chinese rivals
when it came to accessing the latest
rigs and the price tag was sometimes 50
percent more expensive
others are using the same playbook as
can creating corporations that attract
the support of
institutional investors who then help
fund high-tech mining sites
industry insiders and academics who
study mining say that the u.s
efforts can be good for the future of
the cryptocurrency because the original
goal of bitcoin
was to create a currency that couldn't
be controlled by one entity
the dream was that we would reimagine
finance without gatekeepers
and what did we get after 11 years we
got different kind of intermediaries
now mostly nameless mostly under the
covers in china
emin gunsire runs a blockchain startup
and is also an associate professor at
cornell university
he studies the vulnerabilities of
cryptocurrencies and says beijing might
intervene in the market
this is an enormous issue these and
minors they could receive injunctions
that compels them to act in a certain
way
one request he says could be to ask
miners to exclude certain people who
want to spend or accept bitcoins in the
network
essentially blocking transactions this
is what bitcoin academics call
censorship similar to how content and
accounts can be blocked on social media
platforms in china
the chinese governments would say that
the money at certain
addresses must not move and it compels
the chinese miners
to not include certain transactions so
they can
selectively censor certain users of a
blockchain the chinese government did
not respond to a request for comment
bobble finance says if miners in china
are asked by the government to intervene
in the network
they would have to comply but that would
slow down their operations and
eventually diminish their global
processing power
but us minors aren't immune to facing
scrutiny from financial regulators at
home
that have proposed plans to hold the
industry to the same standards
followed by traditional financial
institutions
the more immediate resistance to u.s
minors could come from local communities
concerned about the environmental impact
of bitcoin mining
bitcoin mining consumes enormous amounts
of energy so
all energy that goes to miners is energy
that's being directed
away from other more useful uses
kan says nearly half of the electricity
used by core scientific comes from
carbon free sources
because china's miners aren't part of a
corporate structure like in the us
liu says that they can operate faster
and spend less on operating costs
if you multiply the operational cost
china still has an advantage
china will be on the front of the curve
into the future
2021 is all about expansion and we've
built infrastructure we've built the
software we've built the team
to be a long-term player in this market